el grupo Wagner inició su repliegue de
bahamut tras el anuncio de la captura de
la ciudad la semana pasada Los
mercenarios van a dejar su espacio al
propio ejército ruso así se lo comunicó
a sus tropas el líder y fundador del
grupo Jeff y pregosin
Qué pasa muchachos Eso es todo nos
mudamos en 10 15 minutos todos se van
antes del primero de junio descansaremos
nos prepararemos y luego obtendremos una
nueva tarea
se espera que esta retirada termine
antes de fin de
mayorigosin muy crítico con Los Altos
funcionarios de defensa de Rusia ha
dicho que estarán listos para regresar
si el ejército no puede controlar la
situación
Estos son
vive en el momento en el que el ejército
tenga un momento difícil ellos se
plantarán y bloquearán el paso al
ejército ucraniano desde Ucrania lo ven
como un reagrupamiento por las bajas que
han provocado al grupo Wagner durante
meses la viceministra de defensa
ucraniana reconoció en Telegram el
intercambio de tropas con Rusia
en las afueras de bahamouth el enemigo
ha reemplazado las unidades de Wagner
con fuerzas del ejército regular dentro
de la ciudad misma quedan combatientes
de Wagner
bahamut ha sido la batalla más larga y
Sangrienta de la guerra Wagner reconoció
más de 20.000 bajas mientras Ucrania
está a la espera de realizar una
contraofensiva en la que pueda recuperar
un enclave simbólico Aunque convertido
en escombros
[Música]